the uh paron sculptures were
legitimately acquired by Lord Elgen uh
it was a straightforward contract they
were purchased just like you would
purchase a tisan uh or a rembrand and
there you have it I very much doubt that
the purchase was in any way legal but it
was certainly in many respects under
Jess it was made with the occupying
ottoman forces it was made by a man who
was the British Ambassador at a time
when the Turks wanted British support uh
arguably the agreement even with the
Turkish authorities was simply to sketch
and draw uh the sculptures not to
forcibly remove them when they were
removed uh many of them were damaged uh
and indeed the original intention of
Lord Elgen of course was to display them
in his own estate the only reason they
came into the possession of the British
museum was because Lord Elgen went
bankrupt uh and he also wanted an
English peerage uh and that is the
reason why they ended up in uh the
British museum by Dent of an act of
Parliament and of course at the time it
was still highly controversial and
wildly uh debated at the time it wasn't
a uh unanimous view of the British
public at the time that we were right to
acquire them there is also an argument
which I find profoundly patronizing
which is still used to this day which
somehow depicts the Greeks as somehow
not capable of looking after their own
uh Heritage it's often uh the point is
made that there was an explosion at the
Acropolis when the venetians were
storing ammunition there that happened
about 150 years before Lord Elgen
acquired uh the sculptures and in any
event the sculptures that he so kindly
Left Behind did survive and find their
themselves in the Acropolis Museum a
state-of-the-art modern museum where
they are extremely well cared for and
it's certainly not not the case that the
British museum looked after the
sculptures when they acquired them uh
the notorious fraudster and art dealer
duven who after whom the galleries in
which the parnon sculptures reside is
named uh had them scrubbed clean freshly
white uh in order to be displayed and in
my view they're not particularly well
displayed uh in any event and there's
certainly no uh question that the
British museum can be regarded as having
been a careful Steward of the sculptures
they have uh we know that the British
museum has been in the news recently uh
because of the theft of many uh
artifacts I would not run this argument
as another argument to return the Parn
and sculptures but I would say uh
perhaps that people in glass houses
shouldn't throw stones and the argument
that somehow the Greeks are not capable
of looking after their own Heritage I
think is severely weakened uh if it's
made by a museum that hasn't NE
necessarily shown that it is capable of
caring uh for its own collection so I'm
not going to use that against the
British museum but equally I hope that
argument will now be properly uh dropped
another odd argument that is sometimes
used and it's used was used by David
Cameron when he was asked about this and
it's often used by uh other Prime
Ministers who are always doorstepped
about this issue uh is that this would
be the start of a slippery uh slope uh
that uh somehow all museums would be
duded of their collections uh a good
comparison would be the VNA which is
very prominent in this issue of
restitution which says it's received
nine restitution claims uh uh for its
2.7 million objects that it has in its
possession nine restitution claims in
the last 20 years but the restitution
issue is extremely easy to deal with you
sent you simply set up an independent
committee that can give advice to
museums which doesn't need to be binding
on any uh restitution claim that they uh
receive we do for Nazi art we have the
spoliation committee which quite rightly
looks at the provenance of art that may
have been acquired uh illegally by the
Nazis we do it we have the reviewing
committee for the export of works of art
which quite rightly uh stops objects
which are deemed to be uh inherent to
British culture from being exported if a
public collection can raise the money to
uh purchase them and that is also a
clinching argument for the parnon
sculptures if it's okay for us to set up
a committee that recognizes that there
are objects in this country which are
inherently part of our culture we must
therefore accept the argument that there
are some objects in our Museum which are
inherently tied to the culture of other
countries including Nations as friendly
as uh as the
Greeks